well impersonators are coming
out of the woodwork showing up
in the late night comedy, shows
poking fun at one Republican
congressman George Santos.
And of course is serial lying.
As the old saying goes, well,
the jokes practically right
themselves.
Take a look.
>> Congressman, thank you for
joining us.
>> Thank you for having me
Steven, it's an honor to be a
back on your show.
>> This is actually your first
time here.
>> Not according to my imdb, it
says, I'm going to guess five
times.
I was also your band leader.
>> I'm just in town to pick up
my Nobel peace prize.
>> Congratulations.
>> Four for-able nights at
Madison square garden.
>> I do not know your playing
msg.
>> Yes all the singing all of
my hit songs, piano man, hey
Jude, happy birthday.
>> You are just named to the
house committee on science,
space, and technology.
Does that make sense to you?
>> Well yeah.
Because I was the first openly
gay jewish Republican Latina to
walk on the moon.
To give problems that?
>> That actor in the Jimmy
camel sketch is Nelson
Franklin.
And guess what, he joins me
now.
It's good to see you.
I have to say people are
already talking about who is
going to play him in a movie?
And your name came up time and
time again.
What does it like having, well,
the face of one controversial
congressman these days?
>> It has been a crazy thing,
Laura.
Thank you for having me, by the
way.
I got off Twitter in early 2017,
during the early trump
presidency for my own mental
health.
So I missed a lot of the viral
tweets that were happening
about me looking like this guy.
But my friends and family kind
of forwarded made the
highlights.
It's very weird, that is the
only word I can use to describe
it.
>> I can imagine what's that
like, --
that's our Twitter works, you
cannot leave the family.
So let's talk about you're a
bit on Kamala because frankly
there is a lot of source
material to choose from and
think about it.
I wonder if it makes it easier
for you to approach it and
think about, look I'm gonna go
way over the top, if I was
gonna play the straight there's
enough there.
>> Look I was pretty lucky that
I landed with Kimmel there
because they gave me such a
wonderful script.
I had a huge amount of things
to, do I was walking around the
hallways of congress, I had so
many businesses because I am
too busy to think about how
nervous I am to be on a late
night show for the first time.
So you know, the source for
this bit was just all of that
crazy footage of him walking
down always, evading reporters,
then doubling back and slipping
--
it like you said, you cannot
write this stuff.
So I was just trying to
duplicate the sort of frantic
rambling.
It's like this is what he
would've said if he had opened
his mouth during any of those.
Times >> By the, way I should
tell you that he has tweeted
about.
This he is watched it all and
I'm going to read to you what
he had to say because now I've
been trying the late night TV
history with all these
impersonations.
They're all terrible so far.
John Levinson supposed to be
one of the greatest comedians
of all-time and that was
embarrassing, for him not me.
These Canadians need to step
their game up.
>> First of all he did not talk
about you in that tweet, but he
wants you to step your game up.
That is quite a challenge given
what is ahead and for a man who
has been --
the seals a lot like a satire
and the outages realize.
>>, Yeah you know this is
something that was very
troublesome to the writing
staff in the later seasons.
They would have to change their
scripts because they thought
they thought was so crazy would
actually happen and realize,
they were getting out done by
how crazy reality was.
Look, it is fine.
I'm just disappointed he was
not more excited.
If I was George Santos, if
that's really his name, and I
was in his shoes and people
were parodying me on TV and,
stuff I would be so delighted
by that.
It is such a moment in time.
But of course he's got to stick
to his guns and say everything
is terrible because otherwise
he would not be a GOP
candidate.
>> I do not know that he is not
delighted by those.
He is asking --
he's not telling you to stop,
it was not a shutdown, it was
step your game up.
There is the scene that you
played on Kamala's well
yesterday, you step your game
up.
Here is.
You are him.
>> You've been accused of lying
about a lot of things.
>> Just name ten.
>> How about the pyramid scheme
in Florida that you deny having
any knowledge of.
>> Wow.
Pyramid scheme is an offensive
term, okay.
My people actually built the
pyramids on the roof slaves,
okay.
>> You also claimed to be
jewish but there seems to be no
evidence that you were jewish.
>> Yes, there seems to be no
evidence at all.
Wait a minute.
>> [Laughter]
That's funny.
It's funny.
Why are you groaning?
>> Just looking at myself on TV,
you know how it goes.
>> I like looking at myself on
TV.
In all honesty though, you
should know to take credit for
the entire bit, do not credit
the rioters.
Camel who?
I should ask you are you
planning on reprising this
particular role because it is
funny.
>> I would love to, I had such
a wonderful time working with
those guys it was really good
time.
I'm not sure if it's gonna
happen but this guy cannot stop
the cranking out the material
so there might have to be a
recurring bit there.
>> Something tells me that
there is still more to a story
about all of these things.
I wonder, there are a number of
impersonators now, even across
the late night shows.
I wonder if you are in touch
now and trying to outdo one
another?
>> No, I don't know Jon love.
It's I'm a big fan of John and
Harvey, a big what we do in the
shadows fan, and John Levitz
easy worked a critical line
into his trial of George
Santos.
So these guys are legends and
by ever get to meet them or
consider myself lucky.
>> I'll tell you, I do not
think it's the end of the story,
the end of the bit, there will
be more to come.
It is nice to meet, you can see
that you're very humble but
watching you walk through the